Mày mian áp dùng trong chuyên tạng điện này
thì trong quá trình máy đi ná hổn lắm
thì nó sẽ lắm này
không lắm này như thế
thì người ta giải nghiệp
thì đúng như máy đi náp là người ta dùng dầu
dầu ở đây là dầu máy đi ná
bây tay chào người ta đã dùng dầu
thì dầu máy đi ná có một đặc tính tu vết quân trọng
lỏ nào nó cách nghiệp cái mà
mời vì người hỏi thép và quận dây này
được nâng dầu
dầu của máy đi ná cách nghiệp
rất tốt
thứ hai dầu nó
dạ nhẹ chó quận dây và chó
nói thè
dầu máy đi ná không có một cái
như người ta dùng dầu dầu dầu
rồi của nó cao ở nước
dầu đó cho lình là
cách tính chất và tính lý của nó
ở đây hơn so với nước
bây giờ nếu xôi ở một chân lộ
đó sẽ bình khờ
như thứ mà anh lắm
là
dầu nộ mấy bí náp
nó còn rất châu quận dây
và nói thép không mấy hẹn dơ
o xi hoạ
và ăn ngon
cảm giác
còn nối với nọng cơ nhiên
thì người ta này trời chào người ta để dùng dơ
như vậy trong quá trình đậm cơ hộ hộ nợ
như cơ hộ hộ nợ này
người ta cũng cần phải giảy dết
người ta giảy dết mằng nước và mằng quận mắt
và quả
người cái độ gân dịch này nó không biết quan để điều tổ điện
cho nên người ta dùng dơ
để giảy dết
ở biểu tại không yêu cầu phải cách nghiệp
mà nước kệ
thì nó rất nghiệp
và nó giảy dết cũng rất là tốt
một đặc biểu nâng là
nước có nghiệp
dùng liền lợ
giết dùng liền của nước
gấp hơn 2 là giết dùng liền của dầu
dọn nó cho nên là
để cho nước nó
lắm này
thì phải cắt nghiệp được nhiều
thì chính tỏ như vậy nước này nó
dùng nước có tốt
dùng nước tốt
mà thì nó ai đừng nước thì nó không tốt kẹn
chỉ khi bây